[Musique]
c'est un public bonsoir Je m'appelle
Émilienne et je suis là aujourd'hui pour
vous parler de résilience de
persévérance mais surtout pour vous
parler de mon parcours de ce qui me
permet aujourd'hui d'être debout là
devant vous
imaginez juste un instant que je prenne
quelqu'un dans la salle et que je pose
la question qui ça allait où
je pense que premièrement chacun aura
une réponse différente mais que personne
ne répondra vraiment totalement et
pourtant c'est la question de notre
essence c'est la question de notre
existence et pour moi qui ça au lait ça
a été la question de mon point de départ
vers mon cheminement spirituel et
personnel parce que pour moi les êtres
ne rentrent pas dans les cases et pour
faire face aux aléas de la vie pour être
debout on a tous besoin d'ancrage alors
je vais vous raconter comment ma
construction identitaire à 10 ans à
Paris a été un parcours vers
l'apaisement en tant que femme
réunionnaise d'abord puis en tant que
mère
pour la petite histoire je suis aimée je
suis la benjamine du fratrie de trois
enfants élevé par une mère célibataire
qui elle-même a été élevée par une mère
célibataire de 10 ans
ma grand-mère était le pilier de sa
famille elle était cantinière elle était
aussi entrepreneur à ses heures perdues
parce qu'elle faisait des bonbons
piments pour arrondir ses fins de moi
pour nourrir ses enfants je suis caffine
avec son lot de fardeau de bonheur j'ai
grandi dans un héritage familial très
fort ou les femmes sont tes pouvoirs la
femme élève le Fally quasiment toutes
mes tantes sont célibataires
et avec cet héritage là il y a un
héritage ancestral très fort ou le culte
des ancêtres est au milieu avec ces
codes c'est symboles qui rythme ma vie
au quotidien et c'est avec ce bagage
qu'à 19 ans je me sens pousser des ailes
j'ai envie de partir après un stage à
l'étranger à Paris
faire une école de commerce et puis
rêver et aller plus loin et je pars
pendant 10 ans 10 ans ou ma famille mes
proches mes amis ils voient dans mon
parcours un parcours exemplaire
j'intègre L'Oréal pour mon école de
commerce j'ai une promotion chez Yves
Rocher où je reste 5 ans
pourtant c'est disons là de mon côté ont
été vécus dans une certaine souffrance
ont été vécues comme un exil
je n'ai pas honte de le dire
parce que quand on part à 19 ans loin de
son territoire insulaire loin de sa
famille et qu'on doit trouver sa place
ce construire
affronter les coups et vouloir monter
gravir les échelons on a besoin de force
alors pendant ces 10 ans là qu'est-ce
que j'ai fait pour penser les blessures
de l'exil je suis rentré chaque année
à travers des mois de projection je suis
rentrée chaque année pour le culte des
ancêtres dans ma famille au mois
d'octobre des fois juste deux jours
trois jours parfois parfois une semaine
mais j'avais besoin de cet encrage là
pourquoi parce que ce culte des ancêtres
il me maintenait debout
à chaque fois que je rentrais au mois
d'octobre j'avais besoin de cette dose
de bien-être vous savez comme un enfant
qui attend un patiemment Noël
j'attendais le mois d'octobre
et à chaque année je ressortais encore
plus déterminé ambitieuse
combatif pour me dire aimer les ancêtres
parlent encore
tu es sur le bon chemin
repars et reviens
et j'ai fait ça pendant 10 ans
mais au bout de 4,5 ans cette dose de
bien-être là qui était là comme comme un
addict à la drogue il faut le dire elle
ne suffisait plus pourquoi parce que je
devenais adulte le passage de
l'adolescence à le stade d'Adult et que
j'avais besoin de plus de force pour
gravir les échelons
et en 2015 j'ai eu le déclic de ma vie
tant sur le plan professionnel que
personnel en 2015 j'ai intégré Yves
Rocher où je suis promu sur la zone
internationale 52 marchés où je suis
amené sur une année à voyager au moins
40 fois dans différents marchés où je
suis amené aussi à travailler avec
différents peuples que je ne connais pas
qui ne parle pas mal langue et pourtant
j'y arrive j'y arrive et mes collègues
il s'extasie ils me disent mais aimer
d'où vient cette capacité de créer du
lien avec des gens qui parlent pas ta
langue
d'où vient cette capacité de
compréhension envers ses équipes là
et je le savais pas mais c'était déjà en
moi c'était le premier déclic fin 2014
début 2015 je rencontre aussi l'homme
qui va être mon mari et il vit mon exil
il vit ma douleur je n'ai pas honte de
le dire je lui disais souvent je me sens
incomplète je suis en train de me perdre
je suis en train de me perdre mes
valeurs parce que quand on est à Paris
et qu'on gravit les échelons ils font
rentrer dans les cases
et un jour il me dit mais
tu es bien plus complète que tu ne crois
mais je pense que tu as besoin de
référence pour comprendre ton héritage
et c'est là que je comprends enfin ce
déclic je suis une femme noire deux
handicaps et je me dis ben demain
j'aimerais avoir des enfants comment je
vais faire pour transmettre quelque
chose si je moi-même je n'ai pas cette
force alors je vais aller plus loin et
je me dis que il faut que je comprenne
aussi ma position de femme
et puis que je comprenne ma position de
désentente d'esclaves je suis une femme
avec tous les fardeaux tous les symboles
parce que dans la société on est vu
comme on va dire la partie la plus
fragile de nos sociétés il m'a fallu il
était important pour moi en tout cas de
renforcer cet état d'esprit de femmes
pour pouvoir gravir les échelons mais
aussi pour vaincre les préjugés
qu'impose la condition féminine alors
j'ai lu j'ai beaucoup voyagé j'ai
beaucoup prié
et j'aimerais dire aujourd'hui aux
femmes réunionnaises qui sont ici dans
la salle
nous avons des références
on les ignore mais elles sont là elles
nous regardent leur nom flotte sur tous
les sommets de l'île
mais nous n'y accordons aucune
importance
je parle de qui je parle de Eva de Ryan
de Simon gavold ces femmes là
elles m'ont nourris elles ont réparé mon
exil elles ont pensé mes nuits de doute
à Paris
pourquoi
parce qu'elles étaient conseillères
stratège
tisaneuse guérisseuse combative à chaque
obstacle je m'inspire et des récits à
chaque obstacle
je me disais que j'étais quelqu'un
et que j'avais ma place et que j'étais
légitime parce que je suis leur digne
héritière
ma crise elle a duré 4-5 ans ma crise
identitaire ça paraît beaucoup mais
c'est rien j'avais ces références là et
je me suis dit qu'un jour
pour que mes filles elles puissent
briller il va falloir que je leur
raconte ça
et je suis allé plus loin je me suis dit
bah aimé ben non tu vas te faire
références qui est dans ton univers
réunionnais mais qui sont les vraiment
en dedans conseils
et j'ai fait mon arbre généalogique ma
mère elle avait travaillé déjà sur sa
partie de son côté j'ai fait du côté de
mon père
l'art généalogique ça permet de se
projeter mais comme dans toutes les
familles réunionnaises on a des tabous
on a des traumas
on en parle pas
et pourtant ces récits ont besoin d'être
vécu on a besoin de se nourrir ça fait
mal
on a besoin de se construire alors j'ai
fait mon arme généalogique j'ai fait les
branches j'ai cherché les feuilles mais
j'ai surtout cherchez la forêt dans
laquelle se trouve on arbre
ça a changé ma vie
ces récits-là m'ont porté mon chamboulé
mon bousiller parfois mais j'étais
debout et j'ai envie de vous dire
comprendre son passé c'est le meilleur
remède contre toutes les difficultés
je sais que mon exil était difficile les
gens ils voient mon parcours ils voient
mon ambition mais je sais que ce chemin
là c'est les ancêtres qui l'ont voulu
je brille parfois professionnellement
mais je sais que c'est grâce à eux que
je prie alors j'aimerais juste que vous
vous preniez le temps un jour
de trouver vos références celle qui vous
porte qui vous donne la force d'avancer
celle qui vous construisent
que vous vous intéressez à vos histoires
familiales et que vous vous dites ok
j'ai mal pourquoi je réagis comme ça
pourquoi je suis comme ça aujourd'hui de
mettre des mots sur les mots
et j'espère aussi que vous arriverez à
briller autant
parce que nous sommes leur dignité
vous n'imaginez pas à quel point cette
quête identité
m'a procuré des bienfaits
j'ai pu rentrer à la Réunion et j'ai pu
enfin m'imaginer être mère
au-delà de ça s'il fallait retenir des
bienfaits j'en retiendrai aller 4
le premier bienfait c'est d'avoir pu
nourrir mes racines profondes me
comprendre aujourd'hui je sais ce qui me
fait mal je sais pourquoi je je me
comporte comme ça je sais penser mes
blessures et je sais que ça vient de mon
héritage
je n'ai pas honte je suis debout je suis
solide
au-delà de ça le deuxième bien fait
c'est de nourrir aussi d'améliorer ses
relations familiales
à l'adolescent j'étais j'avais des
relations un peu conflictuelles avec ma
mère je suis parti à Paris j'étais un
petit peu rebelle et je me rappelle une
année où je suis rentré pour la
cérémonie des ancêtres et j'ai rangé la
maison je suis tombé sur un agenda de ma
mère sûrement quand elle était lycéenne
et il y avait une citation de Marcus
Garvey qui disait un peuple qui connaît
ni son histoire ni son origine et sa
culture et comme un arbre sans racine il
R
ce jour là j'ai pleuré pour être honnête
parce que je me suis rendu compte d'une
chose
ma mère elle avait pas eu besoin d'exil
mais elle a eu le même besoin que moi
et là j'ai compris pourquoi elle était
si ambitieuse si stricte s'exigeante
au-delà de ça j'ai envie de vous dire
que ma mère aujourd'hui c'est ma
meilleure amie elle est conseillère elle
est stratège
et au bout de chaque tunnel c'est elle
la lumière
le troisième bienfait de cette quête là
c'était la compassion l'amour
pourquoi parce que c'est récit là ils
m'ont porté ils m'ont nourrit parfois
même choqué j'ai compris ce que les
ancêtres avaient pu endurer et je
compris la puissance et la capacité de
résilience
j'ai arrivé à comprendre et à me
projeter en me disant j'éprouve
aujourd'hui de l'amour de la compassion
j'ai prié pour eux
parce qu'ils m'ont réparé
le dernier bienfait qui pour moi est le
plus important
c'est la résilience
quel peuple et encore debout après temps
de siècles d'esclavage
sans réparation
connaître l'existence de ces valeurs aux
ancêtres ont compris mon permis aussi de
comprendre quelque chose on a une
capacité à surmonter les épreuves
à éprouver des difficultés
qu'importe ce qui se passe ils ont
réussi à tenir et endurer pour que nous
soyons tous debout aujourd'hui
alors j'aimerais que vous aussi vous
fassiez le même chemin que moi j'espère
avoir fait naître une étincelle à
l'intérieur que vous irez aussi chercher
parce que nous sommes leurs dignes
héritiers
ma mère dit souvent
nous prions parce que nous croyons
non
nous prions parce que nous sommes
pensez à votre essence pensez à ce qui
vous fait vivre
dans chaque obstacle de votre vie
pensez au chemin que les ancêtres ont
fait pour vous
nous pouvons et nous devons briller
parce que nous sommes leur digne
héritier
tu es mon bain alors on va le Campagnan
me demande pas mon père
ils ont voulu nous enterrer alors que
nous étions des graines et que nous
finirons toujours par germer merci
[Applaudissements]